what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are jumping into will end of
Weapon X and to be honest I don't think
we've covered no I think we covered one
story so far we haven't covered any of
the others honestly if they have a story
called Weapon H which spins out of this
weapon X is okay I mean it's it's
basically taking like the consolidated
factors of the old Weapon X team are
really more like team X and then kind of
bringing them together
adding in a couple more people so you've
got like Wolverine and Sabretooth who
are part of the team and then you've got
Domino and then you've got Lady
Deathstrike and all in all they are
characters who at one point or another
have all cross paths for whatever you
know by whatever manner and whatever
means so it is kind of interesting for
what it is but the person I do want to
talk about here for a second is
Sabretooth so originally Sabretooth was
an iron fist villain a lot of people
don't know that he would really made his
appearance in iron fist number 14 that's
the reason why if you go and read
all-new all-different iron fist or I
guess really Marvel generations I think
it is or Marvel legacy or whatever the
first story for iron fist kicks off with
round 2 because it's the second time
they're fighting the first having been
and you know the old iron fist issue
number 14 duck in the day and so for
Sabretooth as a character in the old
Chris Claremont stories he never really
had an origin that is to say there
wasn't like an origin story for him he
was just there one day and he was a guy
that had like really rule at the time
that Wolverine had been introduced into
Marvel Comics he was a guy that had like
a long-standing history with Wolverine
now as the years have progressed and
through clear Chris Claremont stories as
well as other stories that have been
written by other writers and Marvel
Comics the origin of Sabretooth has been
fleshed out pretty well in the sense
that he was just a guy who had a really
really abusive father who would yank his
teeth out all the time he was chained up
in the basement his mom wouldn't let him
out wouldn't help me at all eventually
he I think he either cut off or not off
his own hand and then killed his father
so they were like there was some pretty
dark elements to it but the reason why
this matters is in I want to say it's
Wolverine Origins - I know it was in
Wolverine vol 1 issue number 10
regardless what it was there was a
character named Silver Fox back in the
day and Silver Fox was part of the
Blackfoot clan I'm pretty sure that was
based out of Canada and she was a love
interest of Wolverine Sabretooth had
appeared and killed Silver Fox and the
result was that Wolverine kind of went
after him and the two of them would be
on again off again enemies were really
they were constant enemies they would
just meet each other every once in a
while now Sabretooth as you see him now
and all-new all-different marvel is
starkly different from classic
Sabretooth classic Sabretooth was insane
I mean he was just like a feral animal
the reasons why like if you if you were
to take characters from back then and
you were to put them against characters
as they're being depicted now like x-23
no way she would stand a chance against
classic saber-tooth because he was just
like a mindless beast he would just keep
coming after you time and time again
until you until he wore you down until
he killed you but the idea is that he's
basically kind of turned coded and
become a good guy now but with regards
to this whole situation the idea of a
silver fox dying on the birthday of
Wolverine kind of set in motion this
circumstance whereby Sabretooth would
always come after Wolverine on his
birthday and that's what happens here
now what did it bear in mind Greg Pak
writing this story is really kind of
like going with this whole scenario
right like he's assuming that people who
are who are reading this right now are
familiar with this idea but for those
who aren't what he actually does is give
us this little bit of a background here
where you have like Sabretooth who shows
up and immediately starts attacking Wolf
reign a Greg Pak kind of gives us this
this quick little run down where he says
like historically speaking it's always
been this way every year
Sabretooth goes after Wolverine now the
cool thing about this is that in the
saber-tooth origins story Marvel flesh
this out even more and what they did is
they said that like the the vendetta
that Sabretooth horror harbors for wolf
reign is in response to the fact that
Wolverine killed a saber tooth's brother
Luther I can't what is what his actual
name is due to the fact that you know
saber tooth's brother had been involved
in some pretty nefarious schemes and
actually handed over Wolverine or at
least gave the location of Wolverine to
mr. sinister it's kind of like
orchestrated the death of Wolverine love
interest and so on and so forth but the
result of all this is that Sabretooth
always comes after him now this is the
difference this is different between
Sabretooth now versus Sabretooth then
old man Logan is slow if this were
classic Sabretooth from like the 1980s
maybe even the early 1990s no way old
man Logan would stand a chance this
fight would last five minutes long if
that like it I mean it would it would be
it'd be over lickety-split because the
saber-tooth was it was just so insane
back then and there's no other way to
describe it I mean you ever get a chance
to look it up but I might even cover a
video on it but like classic Sabretooth
was bonkers and he was he was awesome
he'll back in the day in terms of how he
worked but the other thing here is that
while he is going after old man Logan
it's not really the same right I mean it
is but it's not it's kind of old I guess
really kind of Sabretooth continuing
this tradition and I would even go as
far as to say as Sabretooth kind of
saying like I see you like classic
Wolverine right because Sabretooth knows
that this is not classic Wolverine right
I mean the whole idea of
people wondering whether or not this is
actually wool rate that's long since
passed everybody knows that he's you
know a version of Logan from an
alternate reality where things just went
totally awry
what is up happening is you basically
have him facing off against us
Sabretooth but you have Logan using
these different tactics at his disposal
you know using various weapons and
different things like that as opposed
just going Adam clawed a clock again if
this was a Chris Claremont story from
like 19 1980 it'd be a totally different
set of circumstances but this is kind of
cool because again oh man Logan doesn't
really want to kill Sabretooth for him
it's just more like I'm not classic
Wolverine I mean we don't really have to
do this but for Sabretooth is his thing
that's that's his whole situation it's
your birthday time for us to fight it's
just the way things are it's the way
they've always been not only that for oh
man Logan fighting Sabretooth kind of
throws off to the to the days of old man
Logan of the actual story where he
killed the x-men and the reason for this
was because he always kind of held
himself back over the years when he
faced off against Sabretooth but never
quite killed him it always kind of held
things at bay and it kept things that
checked the result was that in the old
man Logan story when he was tricked into
believing that all these villains had
invaded the x-men mansion not realizing
he was killing the x-men the result was
that he killed Sabretooth almost right
off the bat and when he I'm sorry he
killed Sabretooth almost right off the
bat and when he did that's what he just
let loose and just essentially killed
everybody else just went insane on
everybody else's so in a lot of ways the
idea is it's a burr tooth it's kind of
what keeps him in check it's kind of the
thing that keeps him from like losing
himself and this is kind of a cool thing
because what Greg pack basically teases
isn't like the classic Wolverine like
the Pharaoh Wolverine the dark sinister
version the one that's just like it's
much of an animal as Sabretooth is
that's still in old man Logan his speed
isn't where it used to be his healing
factor isn't where it used to be but
he's still every bit as dangerous and so
it's kind of one of those things of like
you know where you never know when that
version is gonna come out and it is it
is interesting and I actually kind of
like that idea
I mean I love old man Logan because he's
a lot more processed a lot slower and a
lot more focus than like his his you
know later I guess his younger
counterpart but you know despite that
wisdom that he has on his side working
within his boundaries he is still pretty
nuts and so the fight kind of stretches
all over the place it stretches into the
various animals that are being held
captive by you know Amadeus Cho and all
that kind of cool stuff but the battle
between the two of them is fierce
because where they start to sort of stem
the tide of these various creatures that
are coming after them once they start to
focus again on each other well then it
turns into them basically like
infiltrating a soccer field and then
it's like okay like
we have to find a way to make sure we
keep these people you know keep these
innocents safe and that's the difference
Eddie again this little element here
where we're you know saber-tooth kind of
says hey look decent like don't worry
about the innocents worry about me that
is a little bit of a throwback to his
old school self but again old man Logan
being the good guy Sabretooth is still
kind of being a good guy the two of them
just start focusing on each other and
this is where the cool thing begins to
come in because what happens as old man
Logan says look like I've been holding
back this whole time this fight we've
had where you've been in quote-unquote
getting the upper hand getting the the
better hand on me I've been holding back
do you want me to tell you what happened
to you and like in the future you let me
tell you what happens to you because
that's one of the cool things we never
found out what happened to Sabretooth an
old man Logan we assumed that he died
out or that he was still floating around
there somewhere but we never found out
what we ended up realizing is that in
this area where oh man Logan was taking
up residence in the wait in the
wasteland following the you know
perceived death of his family that
Sabretooth came stumbling by and when he
did Sabretooth had basically turned
feral he'd been living off the land just
kind of doing his own thing killing
various people doing whatever he wanted
to do it really was his paradise in a
lot of different ways and so when he
shows up old man logos response is hey
don't mess with these folks you know
these folks are good they're trying to
live a good life leave them alone and
the response to say were true there's no
there my food like these guys I'm gonna
eat them that's my whole thing and so
over the span of maybe 10 seconds old
man Logan incapacitates him starts
stabbing through him cuts off his hands
and then be capitate him and that's the
end of Sabretooth he dies that fast but
again that's one thing to bear in mind
it kind of creates an interesting
situation here because would Ferrell
Sabretooth from the old man Logan
universe from the wastelands be the same
as classic Sabretooth we don't really
know the indication seems to be that
would be the same in terms of
personality but again like it seems like
a starkly different set of events and so
ultimately where the fight seems to have
this ability to continue on
Sabretooth calls it off it says well
your birthday's done now so you know
back to business
let's go find a bar let's go get a drink
and that's that's the end of that and
that's why I say like it seems kind of
like a saber tooth saying look like I
officially see you as a stand-in for
Wolverine like I see you as my wolf
right now like the guy that I'm gonna be
going against you're not just a guy
who's out there who's a Wolverine from a
different reality you're the guy that
I'm gonna face off against the danger of
all this is that it reminds old man
Logan that at the end of the day while
Sabretooth is being a good guy all it
takes is a slip it takes one event it
takes some circumstance someone
basically giving him a better deal
in order for him to turn back into being
a villain now again when that happens
he'll be a danger to the Weapon X team
as a whole because when it comes down to
it this is why I love Sabretooth so much
when it comes down to it I argue
Sabretooth is it a lot of ways more
dangerous than will rain then then Logan
is because when it comes to old man
Logan and even like classic Wolverine
when it comes to them fighting when
Kasich will reign became a good guy when
he joined the x-men it's the
preservation of life making sure things
stay safe making sure that like
innocents are protected Sabretooth
didn't care about that as long as he got
what he wanted that was the only thing
that mattered he'd kill innocents to get
to Wolverine and so because that it is
cool because it means that if this
Sabretooth falls back to being a villain
again he can become a very dangerous
threat so the idea of Logan is if he's
gonna fall down this path if what he
wants is to just fight and he wants
blood then let's give him that but let's
point him in the right direction
let's make him an you know use him as
the weapon that he is and point him in a
different direction and that's the irony
of this is because old man Logan is
basically taking the stance of Weapon X
essentially saying like you know as the
web annexed organization did to
Wolverine using him hazzard as a weapon
to achieve a goal that's how he's
treating Sabretooth well if he wants to
be a weapon we'll use him as a weapon
and we'll point him and all the guys who
need to be taken down but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later Bruce
[Music]